[Music]
you and lace have split um how are you
doing since that it was not too long ago
how are you doing since the break-up I
mean I've been good you know the
decision to end things was was
definitely for the better I mean I think
that we were both just I mean it was a
situation that was great in the
beginning that ended up being not so
great you know and it's it's good to be
able to realize that and kind of step
away from it instead of having it be
like a long drawn-out situation that
only gets worse you know so yeah well I
talked to both you guys when you did um
reveal that you had broken up and I
think you're both ending this on really
good terms yeah you both seem to be in a
good place about the decision they made
together most definitely I mean it's
like for me I've been through enough and
I've been through enough trials and
tribulations and relationships to know
when something is not working and to
know how to be respectful about it when
when it's not working I get it I mean
you watch the show you see how we were
and everything and that's that's
everyone's first questions like oh my
god what what happened you know and it
was just we were fighting a lot I'm not
gonna lie and it got to the point where
we kind of had so much animosity towards
each other that we just decided that
there's a reason that this isn't working
right now and that you needed to step
away you know yeah so have you talked to
her at all
um I mean we're on wrong good terms do
we talk um no we don't talk on a regular
basis I mean I think that when a
relationship is and did I think that
it's a little bit healthier to kind of
keep your distance from that person
until they can kind of regroup move on
with their life and yeah I mean you can
always be cool with it but I don't I
don't think it's very healthy to like
talk all the time after you break up
it's hard to have that closure you gotta
like start a new life exactly yeah yeah
do you think that it affected you going
from that situation where you're in
Mexico you're isolated it's paradise to
just real life yeah I mean um that
what's great about that setting is that
you get to spend so much time with
somebody and you learn more about them
than you would if you were to date
somebody for like six months
you